what's your general like feeling of
tattoos
oh no they're [ __ ] hairy I actually
hate them so terrible no I'll I can just
hate on my on my first tattoo after I
graduated high school I got like five I
got this this this is this this because
I to be a scammer and I got scammed I
just like tattoo coupons like five
hundred dollars my dad and my brother at
all they both have tattoos my dad has
him everywhere everywhere all over all
on his feet
I'm a cop again this is myself stick
figure me sticking up my middle finger
with the college eyes in this quote
right here I didn't even finish it it
looks like a very cheap ass stenciled
bow
it hurts so bad it was really supposed
to be this very detailed very beautiful
boat boat boy that bracelet that sits
right here yeah I just like where it's
it so I just put it there eternally my
mom's name on my left wrist cuz my dad
has his mom's name once again just being
a copy jack
I have a barcode on this race and the
numbers are the area code of Georgia so
it's like I'm a product of Atlanta I had
this originally over here but it looked
terrible so I just scribbled it out I
just scribble it out like lucky I got
this very an even anchor MCC and I got
in a scene in font first the others of
my last name
it's a D and so RR g was like my first
rapping in like high school like I used
to call myself our D na z na c YC SKT
till I died in a desert YC Yacht Club
SKT skiing team he stood like my three
gangs like my homies that grew up with
until I died you know I'm saying God
never put a tattoo in my face so I'm
beautiful sheen heavens no this is my
moneymaker
I have mommy's baby on this on Daddy's
soldier on this I Q see my label
I got a lightning boat everybody in
selling team has a lightning bolt
I don't have any girls name sauce my
mother I haven't been in like love so I
fight from love [ __ ]